this is most of the graph that I'm
expecting to see on your page and some
of them are some of them still need a
bit of work this is what we produced in
desmos it's the model we constructed
with one big difference right when you
put something into Des Barres
it's a cosine function it just goes
forever right it just goes on and on and
on but we only want a part of it
the first three minutes right so we
start at time zero there's our time axis
over this way a certain time zero and
what's the final time on line what
should it be if it's the seconds it's
180 right so there's 180 seconds you can
see halfway is it 90 and that's why it's
one full period of motion and I've got a
few other pointers that a market and
marked in and these are important right
so you can see these other things on the
time axis what do you think those times
are like what do you think the actual
numbers are
45 and 135 why do those numbers matter
to this particular graph max yep
that's the highest point right you can
see me sort of mapping it up to their
tavares the question before do I have to
have this line down the bottom the short
answer is no but I put it in when i
graph anyway because it's actually quite
hard to graph this accurately and I want
to know where the bottom point of the
graph is and have that accurate okay I
suppose I probably could have put the
top one as well which is what by the way
what is the top 72 where did silly to
come from very good so I've got this
radius of 35 so are you good to go I've
got a radius of 35 which means I've got
a diameter of 70 which is why so if you
doubled and what's the middle spot by
the way this this middle spot right here
this is 30 we added on something to this
graph do you remember we went plus 37
thank you why is it 37 because I've got
the two at the bottom and then here's
the radius of 35 said okay what do you
think the graph is it good enough I'm
pretty okay yeah just yeah I'd give it a
give it four stars okay all right now
Zack you know I'm gonna ask you to hit
pause on that because you'll probably
have a look at the next question I don't
want everyone's attention all right B
and C I'm coming at a quick show of
hands who's already started on B at
least
yep okay thank you hands down let's
let's have a go together it says what is
a cabin and you know the cabins the
thing on the ferris wheel right what's a
cabins height above the ground in meters
after 30 seconds so have a look I've got
0 45 and 90 marked in on my graph wrong
choice of color let's go green so 30 is
somewhere around there's 15 and 30 are
you ok with that
yes 30 so I'm expecting a number
somewhere around here
yeah 54.5 okay let's let's have a go
right have I have I done something
drastically wrong on my graph I feel
like I have what have I done wrong
because I'm hey I think it's the my
gradient is really bad
yeah migrating Israel oh I know what I
did yeah no no no I just actually this
is this should be further along should
be more like here that's better so I
look better from you guys you guys can
see the board better than I can
yeah okay that's more like it alright
now how do we actually punch in this
number well we've got for Part B we've
got an equation for this right little
little people all right let's see if we
can confirm this right H equals what if
I got is my actual equation minus minus
35 cos and then in the bracket C what am
i checking in I'm checking in 30 on 45
and then don't forget there's the PI
also hanging around from there right
okay so I've put in 30 for time right
it's a time thing yeah so X was what you
did for des mots because it wants an X
but it's TT for time right is this the
whole equation what am I missing
plus 37 very good now real quickly you
can go to your calculator for this right
but I want to confirm what we've got
here 31:45 what fraction is that 30 on
45 what's it simplify to that's 2/3
right to play on 3 do we know our exact
values for 2 pi on 3 cos of 2 pi on 3
think think think
two pi on three this is like 120 degrees
in degrees anyway so the relative angle
would be 60 degrees but I'm in my second
quadrant so cos is negative there so it
should be negative 1/2 you can go ahead
and you can check that out okay there's
my 37 half of 35 we already worked out
this before when Zack he was doing the
other graphs it's 17 and 1/2 plus 37 is
that the 54.5 that you guys worked out
we nailed it okay now at this point by
the way please note that I've not
finished answering the question at this
exact point right read the wording of
the question what does it ask what's it
ask it says it says read well you tell
me that's already the plus two is
already included in there 37 right it
says what is the cabins height above the
ground is that 54 point five millimeters
or centimeters or kilometers as meters
right so I would say the safest way the
best way to answer this is to say the
cabin is there's my actual distance 50
4.5 meters above the ground now the
interpretation of your answer it's not
just taking the number and slapping a
unit on it right if we have a look at
temperatures or tides things like that
right these actually can't go above or
below they might mean left or right so
it's really crucial that you interpret
your answer and provide with the
sentence if they ask you the question in
a sentence of a yeah
this part here yeah let's have a look
can someone helps out where did that
what did this replace in the line before
well it almost the toupee on three
something else disappeared from this
line to the next clothes right so close
of two point three this is an exact
value our paisan for our PI on three
these are exact values that we should
actually be starting to learn and commit
to memory for something like this
sure pop it into your calculator it's
okay I don't trust myself either so I
checked it anyway but you want to flex
your brain so you actually learn these
exact values they become enormously
useful they just make you faster right I
can stand up here without a calculator
and know that if my calculator is
telling me something different I've
punched it in wrong okay all right now
just real quick because I think most of
you are ahead of me at this point I'm
going to show you yeah I'm going to show
you my answer for the last one just so
you can compare I'm impressed you've got
an answer sounds like a degrees with
mine
very nice I'm impressed very good here's
my answer for Part C and you can see the
way I've set it out it's pretty
important here's the answer we're going
for but actually all this stuff is the
stuff that really matters in fact I
could just as equally give you a
question which says show that the cavern
is 40 meters above the ground at this
time like I might give you that time
right in that case I'm looking for all
of this this is the stuff that actually
matters okay because it's your reasoning
and it shows that I know what I'm doing
and how to solve it okay